it's a funny thing i don't take
mushrooms as much as i used to
when i took them a lot i believed
stranger things about them than i do
now that tells me that i am
corrupting the purity of what i knew
i'm trying to make it more rationally
apprehendable than it actually is
it isn't rationally apprehendable i
you know it's pressure on the
imagination
to imagine what could be going on is it
possible that the mushroom
is a technical artifact can we
conceive of a civilization so
sophisticated
that this would be a machine that they
would make
and when you start looking at the
mushroom from that point of view
it's weird how it cooperates
because mushrooms grow from spores
are very very small they have
an outer shell which is one of the
hardest
materials to occur in organic nature
it achieves its hardness through an
extreme electron density
an electron density so great that it
approaches that of
gold an almost superconducting metal
what does that mean it means that if
this spore were suspended in a high
vacuum with an electrostatic charge
that it would form global currents on
itself on a surface
that would repel incoming radiation
up to a certain energy level
in other words the spore looks like
something evolved to survive
conditions very similar to outer space
well then if you've ever seriously
looked at the problem of
extraterrestrial communication and
strategies for extra
there are two ways to think about
extraterrestrial communication
one is not very interesting it's that
the extraterrestrials have god-like
powers and therefore there's no reason
to try and anticipate
how they would do it because we can't
but if you take the other view
that the distances between the stars are
real that the speed of light
is a fairly high barrier and so forth
now what kind of strategy would you
construct
if you were trying to explore the
universe for life
i think you would find a way to build
tiny spaceships hundreds of millions
of spaceships say one micron in diameter
and then you would just disperse them as
an aerosol
into deep space where light pressure
and this sort of thing would move them
around and you would do it in such
den in such numbers that
some tiny percentage would eventually
reach
habitats with sufficient
nutritional and temperature regimes
that the that they could grow
and then uh influence
that bio system eventually to the point
where
it's it's called the phone home strategy
you can't search the entire universe for
life
you have to send out a message which
says
if you are reading this message call the
following
toll-free number for further
instructions
and that's what the mushroom seems to be
saying it's saying
if you are an intelligent life form
you know plug in the following toll-free
number for further instructions
now it's interesting there is a gnostic
sect
in the middle east a quasi-gnostic sect
that has survived into the present day
called the mandayans or mundayans
who live in the swamps of iraq and iran
they have a belief which they have kept
intact for 2000 years in a messiah
but it's a strange messiah he's an
engineer he builds a machine
he doesn't have a teaching he builds a
machine
for transmitting souls back to their
higher and hidden source
beyond the pleroma of appearances
and this is what the mandayan's weight
is the messiah with the blueprint for
the soul transmitting machine
the fact that inside the mushroom is all
this ufo
stuff uh the strangest things
happen when you begin probing
the practical details related to the ufo
phenomenon
they get very nervous this is where the
conversations ensue
about if i show it to you you'll
understand how it works
kind of thing uh
so i don't rule out the possibility that
we actually are dealing
with an other that has but and i think
you know what
ticks me off or irks me about all the
other extraterrestrial scenarios
is that they're so mundane
you know i don't want to meet
extraterrestrials that are so
stupid that they crash their ships in
the desert and end up
on ice in some air force base i don't
want to know aliens
so tasteless that they erect anthropoid
beetle-browed structures on mars on a
scale of 12
by 15 miles we got enough bad
taste as it is we don't need that kind
of thing
an extraterrestrial is you may bank on
it
going to be subtle the trick will be to
recognize it
they're not going to appear with a
trumpet blast in ships the size of
manhattan over every city on earth
it won't be like that it's subtle
to be to recognize it will be the trick
and then when you sort and if somebody
were seriously interested in
extraterrestrial life
as the government claims it is what
would any reasonable person do
they would make a full catalog of
terrestrial life
and see if there's anything in there
that stands out
that doesn't look right that may be you
know tracked in mud from somewhere
else well how about it what is
psilocybin
psilocybin is for phosphoryloxy
nnn dimethyltryptamine the only
four phosphorylated indole in organic
nature on this planet
it's sticking up like a sore throat
thumb there is no other four
phosphorylated indole on this planet
so what is this thing doing in the
genome
of this higher organism uh
i think you know that the
experience of the mushroom is
sufficiently peculiar
that it's the best candidate around for
being a true
other and you know
once we accepted that it wouldn't seem
that surprising science would explain to
us how we should have known this all the
time and that of
course stuff was drifting in here i mean
i would predict
a revolution waiting to be made in
biology
on the that's similar to the plate
tectonic revolution in geology
is somebody needs to just stand up and
say in a loud clear voice
space is no barrier to the transmission
of life
we are not on an island earth starseed
it's percolating you know even at light
pressure if you released an aerosol
cloud
at some point in the galaxy of spores
by light pressure and radiation pressure
alone those spores could find their way
to every other part of the galaxy
in less than 200 000 years well the
universe is old
200 000 years is nothing i mean so we
are living on an island
granted space is a barrier but life is
drifting
in here all the time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you